for years Mouse manufacturers have been
competing to Dethrone the reigning Kings
Logitech the g-pro and the super light
are some of the best selling gaming mice
ever produced and even years after their
release companies are still trying to
steal logitech's Thunder these are
easily some of the most high optimized
to come out this year and for pretty
good reason I mean on paper you're
getting a mouse that is better than the
Jeepers super light newer sensor better
shape better click feel and actually for
less money but the days of the super
light's dominance some might be coming
to an end many manufacturers are
stuffing their mice with new features
and they think that 4K polling rates
will get you to switch to their products
but Logitech doesn't even seem to care
about that for the last little while
we've endured incremental updates to the
big mice and now a big shift is coming
are we really entering a new era of
gaming mice are 4K mice worth it and and
can anyone actually take down Logitech
[Applause]
all right so before we dive into all the
mouse talk I must encourage you all to
please like the video subscribe to the
channel and turn on notifications that
way you'll never miss our next episode
of cracked it's no secret that the
gaming mouse Market has been pretty dry
as of late but one fairly big
manufacturer has really been dragging
their feet for years logitech's G Pro
and eventually super light were the gold
standard of gaming mice Logitech worked
with Pros to craft a safe shape that
works for almost any type of player and
it worked the super light is one of the
most beloved popular gaming mice ever
made but things have changed since its
release back in 2021. the hardware has
been surpassed as more and more
companies challenge logitech's
Stranglehold on the gaming world the
sensor is outdated it still uses micro
USB and at this point the so-called
super light is actually heavier than
many of its competitors they may not
have reached zowie levels of complacency
but I think it's fair to say that the
time has come for Logitech to release an
updated version of the super light and
that's why the internet went nuts a few
months ago when Logitech baited all of
us into thinking it was finally
happening only to release a new headset
but lately rumors of a new mouse have
started to feel much more real
absolutely
it's on the release
simple is a long time super light user
and was even one of the first players to
test the original g-pro back in the day
that combined with the fact that Navi is
partnered with Logitech made the super
light 2's imminent release feel pretty
realistic and not long after leaked
images suggested that the new mouse
would be lighter Implement a new skate
design use new switches and a new sensor
but the alleged 2K polling rate is what
really caught everyone's attention many
consumers were disappointed to see that
after all this time the super light 2
didn't support higher polling rates or
look all that different to be fair a lot
of companies spent most of this year
just releasing the same mice over and
over again in different colors with
pretty minimal changes we saw Pulsar
Implement Optical switches on the X2
Bruce Lee Edition lamzu proved that they
could compete with the Atlantis and
Atlantis mini and zawi finally added
Wireless to one Mouse
one
still pissed look it's better late than
never I guess but the idea is that we
want Innovation most manufacturers are
just shaving weight off their existing
mice what we want is something new that
really will give us an advantage in the
server and some believe that high
polling rates are the answer over the
past few months more and more 4K and AK
options have been popping up while every
peripheral junkie searches for their
next endgame Mouse High polling rate
mice have popped up from time to time
over the past couple of years but
they've really only managed to reach the
small niche market of peripheral
obsessed consumers who will try just
about anything but nowadays companies
clearly want you to care about polling
rates even so-called Normie mice like
the Death Adder support 4K but does it
really matter will a 4K Mouse suddenly
turn you into demon one what the [__] is
a polling rate and how does it actually
affect my gameplay well you see
I actually have no idea so I brought
along my good pal Colton and now the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about of course you brought me along
what Dimitri you were gonna turn this
technical mumbo jumbo into something
mildly interesting now thankfully for
you and I polling rate is actually a
pretty simple concept polling rate
refers to the frequency at which your
mouse sends data to your computer
measured in Hertz in a perfect world
with a higher polling rate your clicks
and mouse movements should feel smoother
and more responsive but of course this
is not a perfect world up until very
recently a thousand Hertz was pretty
much the gold standard when it came to
gaming mice but in recent years we've
seen most manufacturers dipping their
toes into two thousand four thousand and
even 8 000 Hertz polling rates on their
premium Mouse offerings so why isn't
every Pro just rocking a mouse with 30
000 Hertz polling rate well first let's
talk about the obvious diminishing
returns I mean if you're gonna tell me
you can feel the difference between 0.5
milliseconds at 2 000 Hertz and 0.25
milliseconds at 4 000 Hertz then you
need to call my man Professor Xavier the
second issue is a little less obvious as
it turns out having your mouse update
its position more than a thousand times
a second will start to have a noticeable
impact on your CPU enough that you will
notice some impact on your frame rates
especially as you approach 8 000 Hertz
on older Hardware in our video about the
vaxi XE Wireless a few months back we
discussed the company's decision to
stick to a thousand Hertz polling when
it comes to Esports players competing at
the highest level need to know that
their equipment won't fail them on the
biggest stage so vaxi released the XE
Wireless with them in mind using a
special simulated interference
environment our teams work together to
test and make the adjustments required
to meet the high standards of
responsiveness and reliability required
in profession National gaming to make
this simple number even more
controversial you may not even see the
benefits of a higher polling rate if
your DPI is below 1600 we and by we I
mean I gave you a rundown on what DPI is
in a video so old even my mustache looks
younger but let's skip right to the
reason why this is it all comes down to
information to vastly oversimplify it
you can think of a higher DPI like a
higher resolution on a camera so a
higher DPI means your mouse sensor is
registering smaller movements generating
more information and you'll see a more
noticeable impact from more frequent
updates which is why the consensus seems
to be that you should aim for a
comfortable DPI at or above 1600 if
you're using a 4000 and especially 8 000
Hertz polling rate is the difference
here small I mean yeah that's why you
don't see every Esports Pro doing this
my very non-professional opinion
anything above a thousand Hertz is
pretty much just personal preference if
you can afford to ball out with more
expensive Hardware then go nuts but I am
a man of science not opinions want us to
do a comprehensive Mouse settings study
I know I do then tell my bosses in the
comments so I can show them and bend
them to my science loving will in theory
higher polling rates should perform
better but that isn't always the case as
more mice start to implement four
thousand and eight thousand Hertz
sensors that's definitely something you
should keep in mind for your setup and
that was the guy who actually knows what
he's talking about so 4K is slowly
becoming the norm we've even seen some
smaller manufacturers like lamzu and
Pulsar throw their names into the Hat
over the past couple of months and
they've been fairly well received but is
the difference between 2K and 4K really
that noticeable like are people just
overreacting about the super light two
specs keep in mind the original G Pro
was made to appeal to 99 of Gamers not
people like Nile who want to try each
and every mouse that gets released and
they're selling to a mass amount of
customers they're not selling to the
niche one percent of people who want 4K
um and then the other way to look at it
is not everybody has you know a top of
the line PC that can handle 4K polling
right right
so imagine you you saw the mouse with 4K
right and then I don't know you got a 15
year old kid who has a PC that her
parents just bought them and it was what
they could afford or whatever and the
kid starts having stutter issues and
everything because he's using miles from
4K
and it ends up being a return now a lot
of 4K mice don't only run at 4K sure it
might seem like a waste of money to buy
a mouse capable of running High polling
rates and sticking to a thousand Hertz
but if it prevents your game from
stuttering because your Hardware simply
can't handle 4K then I think it's a
pretty easy decision 4K may seem like
the next great thing in the gaming world
and honestly it has the potential to
beat just that but just because a mouse
is capable of running 4000 Hertz doesn't
always mean that you'll have a better
experience the way that each company
implements 4K can differ and some tech
reviewers have already demonstrated that
not every Mouse running higher polling
rates is automatically better even Nile
who has used a lot of these products
still believes that his 1K XE Wireless
with vaxi's competitive firmware feels
pretty damn close to his 4K Death Adder
and X2 V2 not to mention the fact that
higher polling rates are much more
taxing on your CPU and the mouse's
battery life so if you're thinking about
pulling the trigger on a new 4k or 8K
Mouse please be sure that your computer
can actually handle it first and these
are decisions that I'm sure a lot of you
will have to make as 4K and 8K mice
continue becoming the norm would you
rather play on a high polling rate with
a high click latency or have a smooth
gaming experience think about it every
Mouse coming out of China right now also
has a 33.95 the same switches the same
polling rate they all have 4K but
they're being sold for like 60 bucks so
that implementation of 4K is
it still has higher click latency than
the Logitech G Pro that came out
freaking three years ago I think it's
all about how you implement the tech
right I wouldn't be surprised if their
2K implementation is probably on par
with a lot of 4K stuff that's like
really good at the moment Logitech
really took their time when it came to
updating the super light and to be fair
they didn't really have to change it in
the first place it's still widely used
by casual players and Pros despite the
fact that some of the hardware is
outdated if anything the decision
probably stemmed from logitech's
competitors pushing their own technology
forward and consumers just clamoring for
something new it might not be the
upgrade that everyone was hoping for but
it's definitely a step in the right
direction they haven't innovated in a
while
um you know and their stuff is like a
staple right like the G Pro is a staple
their 305 is a staple they redid the 303
because they're trout and stuff like
that but
they are behind their competition now in
terms of specs and stuff and they know
that right they I mean they spend
millions of dollars a year I bet in r d
and stuff so
will they do something to you know catch
up to competition or probably even you
know take it a step further I think they
will I wouldn't be surprised like I said
if Logitech comes out with a software
update or something to support a much
higher polling rate after a somewhat
slow start to the year the mouse war is
starting to heat up again plenty of
brands have dropped new products over
the past few months and with a new super
light on the horizon there's a lot to be
excited about our high polling rate
features necessarily for you
that's for you to decide but if the
super light 2 somehow flops maybe
logitech's reign will finally come to an
end I have never I pay no mind to it I
don't care about the Logitech super
lights
um not because I think it's a bad Mouse
but because since the day the G Pro came
out it has been too small for me it is a
tiny little mice mouse that they refuse
to make a larger size of and so I just
don't care